Thank you so much for being here
guys. Have a seat. Let's chat.
I know this is Google cause
we're miked right here.
Might all this tech is here and
cameras are all set up. It's, you know,
a Google the place. So, um, first
of all, welcome to Google Chicago.
We are so excited to have you guys
here. This movie is incredible. Um,
I guess I really shouldn't be saying
welcome to Chicago for you because you are
kind of a Chicago Guy, right? Yep.
I lived here 11 years.
Incredible. Yeah. Any love to hear?
I mean obviously you've done some amazing
work around Chicago stories, right?
Whole food barbershop.
Yeah.
Yup. Roll bounce. Right. I did about
at least about six, seven movies here.
Actually, one thing I'm very proud of
with my business partner Bob title,
when Obama was here, um, you know,
he actually greenlit the
tax incentive for film.
So we were one of the first major
guys to allow five, you know,
movies to come to Chicago with
a nice discount for a filmmaker.
So I was really proud of
that. Wild is, yeah. Yeah.
That's just incredible to me.
And so one of the things that I see as
a consistent theme through some of your
films is the fact that you have a pension
for telling stories about the culture,
all sides of the culture, right? You know,
you get your sadness and your happiness,
you get the joy and that's a lot of what
we get in the hate you give. So yeah.
Tell me, what about this book and
the screenplay drew you to it.
Why did you want to tell
this story specifically?
Yeah. What I really love about it was
it was specifically about the culture,
about this young girl and her family.
You know,
the ideal of navigating
between the two worlds.
So the ideal of her struggling and
then that being compromised when she
witnessed the shooting of her best friend.
I just thought that was an
interesting character arc.
But what I love is how the family is
always centered and no matter how tough
things get,
no matter how you know,
people in the neighborhood telling her
not to say anything about the shooting or
how much pressure she feels
from the police department
and how much pressure she
feels from her white friends,
her white private school,
she just push us and it makes the
film has this emotional rollercoaster.
Where are you going
through all these emotions?
That's what I really imagine envision
for the movie. When I talked to Angie,
because her book was very amazing,
but what I really love is how,
which I find really significant is that
you can tell a movie about this specific
culture,
but it can be for everyone.
You can do it with a way where
you're not compromising who we are.
And I think that's the key.
Yeah,
and that's one of the things that was
the most beautiful about it. I mean,
it's the kind of movie that can speak
to a range of audiences and really
welcomes them in with open arms,
which is so incredible and hard to do.
I think so. Amandla for you.
What brought you to this movie?
So I hear
that you signed on even
before the book was published,
you were all in ready to go. This list
for you. How did you make that decision?
What connected you to star story?
Um,
what connected me to this story
was the book by Angie Thomas.
And if you haven't read it,
I highly recommend that you do because
it is so beautiful. Second that, um, uh,
yeah,
I was immediately just blown away by
this story and the power that it had in
depicting a nuanced experience of
blackness in a contemporary world.
I felt like not often are we afforded
those sorts of representations.
And so it was really exhilarating to me
to see this girl who was code switching,
you know, um, who was presenting
herself differently in
different spaces. Right. Um,
and then the way in which she's galvanized
towards activism because of these
really tragic events that we've often
become desensitized, desensitized to.
So to see those placed in a personal
narrative and to understand the power of,
you know,
instilling empathy in people through that.
But that's what really drew me to it.
And so you mentioned code switching and
that's a term that's kind of gaining
more and more attention as people are
trying to understand what it is to be a
person of color and two different spaces
in the world of white space and a black
space.
Can you explain a little bit more about
that and how star sees herself code
switching in the movie,
the specific situations that she feels
that she needs to make that change?
Yeah, sure. So I'm code
switching is, you know,
entering spaces that you know, you're
not necessarily fully accepted into.
And so understanding that the way that
you present yourself in that space might
be a little different from how you are
and your most authentic environment
because you understand that if you
present as authentically as you are,
it could be detrimental to your success,
unfortunately.
Or you can be further
alienated or isolated. Um,
which is something that everyone does,
you know,
and they're at home and probably a little
different than who you are at work or
at school. Um, but stars really
caught in this dichotomy,
which I actually experienced as well,
um,
of growing up in a
neighborhood that is black, um,
and has a lot less privileged than the
neighborhood that the kids at her school
are from because she goes to this school
an hour and a half across town. Um,
that's mostly white.
And so she's one of the only black
students there and she does a lot of self
policing because she knows that these
kids don't understand her experience of
blackness, don't understand her
community or who she is or her culture.
And so she figures out how to adjust
to that environment in order to be more
accepted.
Absolutely.
And so the way that that manifests in
the film is she has star version one and
star version two. And, and when
I first read it in the bucket,
it really just,
it registered in a way like I've never
seen it depicted like in any sort of
piece of media before. Um, where,
where star describes the experience of
feeling and hearing your voice change,
right? When you enter a space that
you're not most comfortable in a,
or at least when you enter a white
space in which you understand that your
blackness will not be understood.
Right.
So I've really connected to that
and this whole idea of star being,
you know,
kind of canonized by her
peers at school as a,
an accessible black girl,
as a nonthreatening black girl,
as a not like other black people,
black girl, you're different,
you're different. You're
not like them. Um,
which is just so kind of invalidating
and simplifies our existence in a way
that's really detrimental.
So it was so exhilarating to me to see
a portrayal of a black girl that was
actually reflective of our experiences.
And that was really expansive and all
encompassing and multifaceted because
oftentimes, you know, we're,
we're only given a certain amount
of tropes that were allowed to play.
It's a little box. Sometimes there's
a little box. Yeah. We can play, uh,
the humor. We can play the pain. Yeah.
But not often is it that
we get to be everything.
And so that's what was so exhilarating
about reading this character. Um,
you're right. And the unpublished
manuscript and wasn't out yet, but it was,
it was floating around because
people were so excited about it.
And I attached really early on
your heart latched on for sure.
My battery on that says something
about the work for sure. Yeah. Um,
another thing that I kind of want to
discuss, I mean it's super, super timely.
Obviously police brutality is on the
top of mind for so many people and
especially here in Chicago with
the case of [inaudible] Mcdonald's,
Jason Landegg just being
convicted for his murder. Um,
what is the importance of a movie like
this landing at this time? You know,
there's never a right time to,
to talk about the hard things,
but it seems like this is almost healing
in a way for this movie to happen right
now as some things are
changing in America.
Yeah. I just felt like, um, you know,
it was just that we were just in,
I was just telling a Madela like when
we were in Atlanta last week and, um,
and we finished the screening and someone
tapped me on my shoulder and I turned
around, he asked, can we take
a picture? And I was like,
yeah, we can take a picture.
And he'd like, thank you so
much for the movie. And he said,
we are the family of Emmett till.
And, and I was like, you know,
just kind of blow me away. It was
the whole family, like six of them.
And I just think back to, you know,
Ayman Til being here from Chicago,
going down to Mississippi. You
know, he had sort of the early,
because his mom was telling him how
to act down in Mississippi. Right.
And how to conduct yourself as a
little different from down there.
So that talk is something that
you progress over the years.
It probably was started through
slavery, you know, when,
when we were free and how do
you act around certain people.
So I just felt like it was very important
for other cultures to be able to
recognize and see that,
you know the talk to some people
it's like the birds and the bees,
but for us or African Americans or
people of color, it's a difference.
So I'm in a young girl like star,
just have to navigate
and keep pushing through.
She's very much of the world
and know how to interact.
I don't know how to move inside her guard
heart hikes world, but she has another,
we have these other
things on this as well.
So a lot of that is just to let people,
as Angie was say,
who wrote the book is to have empathy,
what people go through and
also recognizing how did
these things happen and in
the shooting of the cop,
why did he react the way he react?
We talked about that and we see it from
a black cop perspective with comments
and we'll see sometimes is
not that much of a difference.
So when you think about that, it has
to be the system, right? The system.
How did they teach cops? What
did they, who are in charge,
who are the leaders inside
those departments? And we
don't condemn. We don't.
We just show what the reality
is so we can cause conversation.
I thought Commons character, uncle Carlos
was so unique. Like you were saying,
you don't often get the
perspective of a black cop.
I mean it's such an interesting
situation to be and where you know,
you see what the people are going through,
you understand you're part of the culture.
And then also being kind of on the
other side of these are your coworkers,
these are your colleagues and
how do you speak up? So He's,
he's so nuanced in that way.
Yeah, it is. It is true. I mean that's,
let's say all of us in this room,
we all have it inside of us.
I mean let's just take
comes character myself.
Like as an African American man,
it is a conversation that
we have had in rehearsals.
If I'm walking on the
south side of Chicago,
if I'm by myself as an
African American man,
and if I see three African American guys
walking on the other side of the street
and they walk over here, I'm going
to think something's up, right?
I'm gonna move over to car,
cross the street.
So that's that own internal
racism that I have within myself,
within my own culture.
So that has to be broken.
That's what common realizes when
this young girl start confronts him.
And those are the kinds of
dialogues that the movie brings up.
You know what I mean?
On both sides.
Beautifully done.
I think Angie's,
you know,
intention with the book was to like
present these topics and these issues in a
way that was, yeah, I've come that was
inclusive of different perspectives.
Um, that didn't further
perpetuated divisiveness, you know,
that grounded it in humanity and like
we always get asked about the timeliness
of this project. Yeah. But the thing is,
has been timely for a really long time.
Waste unfortunately, will
probably be timely for awhile. Um,
but we always get asked is also
really interesting question.
Or I think last night we
got asked it, which was, um,
what is the role of an
artist in social movements?
Like what is the role of
the filmmaker? Um, you know,
when is it time to make art and then when
is it time to get up and go out in the
streets and protest. And, um,
and I think they're so
interconnected and both are so,
are so invaluable.
They weren't off of each other and they
work off of each other as, you know,
like art has always been one of the
driving forces are conduits for social
movements.
Absolutely.
Like they have like a really
beautiful symbiotic relationship.
And so I think that was the driving force
behind this pieces to make something
that in the midst of what feels like
chaos and what feels like times in which
things are postulated is
so black and white, right,
wrong versus right. Me versus
you, um, winner versus loser.
Uh,
I think it was,
it felt important to create something
that explored it in a way that would
ground us and what makes us most
human and understand that every single
experiences is multifaceted.
And it requires a,
in order for there to be any sort of
movement made or any progress made,
do you have to consider even your enemy
in a way that is not one dimensional.
Right. And it also comes down to empathy,
like you were saying before, just being,
um, being able to understand and look at
another side or perspective. Yeah. Um,
you mentioned the humanity in this, you
know, there's so much going on this movie,
there are so many themes,
but one of the things that I found really
interesting is your portrayal of the
black family. Right? Um, you don't get
a lot of that and TV. I mean we're,
we're starting to get there a little bit
more with shows like blackish and we're
normalizing it.
Um,
but maverick is such an
interesting character as well
because he is this father
who is so complex and you know,
he's done time and it wasn't
necessarily his fault,
but he's coming from this one life
that he had before and it's kind of
completely switching into a new
role and he's being a father. Um,
I'm interested to know what was the most
important thing to you when you were
portraying black masculinity and
fatherhood and the home in this movie?
Yeah. One of the things that,
um, that I love that, you know,
the perspective of having a father in the,
in a movie like this,
because you know,
when I look back,
I've been making films for for a little
bit since the 90 [inaudible] that full
out.
So when you look back at it,
I say some of the African American
characters that films that have African
American characters in it,
80 70% of them don't have a father figure
in the household was always a single
parent.
And that's not the case
in the neighborhood that I
grew up and I had fathers
next to me to the left or right of me.
It was a community.
The community actually raised everyone.
And that was always a barbershop like
Mr. Lewis and always a barbecue joint.
And like Mr Reuben, you know,
like, I don't know if, you know,
you noticed on the wall it was like he
would give kids free barbecue if they,
he sees their report cards and that's
the kind of re that's the kind of thing
that we wanted to bring community
back. Uh, one of the main thing is, um,
I love their relationship.
It was very strong in the book
between Matt and his daughter.
And I thought that was great.
And one of the things I love to say is
that the family has so much joy in it.
A, we had so many levels of
humor. Yeah. Believe it or not,
there's a lot of humor in that movie.
It'd be a lot of emotion and it's fun.
You will be entertained.
But it just were issues that
we see every day. And um,
I really do believe that film
is an entertaining venue.
That's why people pay to go see movies,
to be entertained. But the movie has that,
but you'd be able to relate to it because
there's the family and no matter all
of these obstacles they
keep pushing through.
They keep going through and at the
end we see star has her journey.
And that's the main thing that I'm
really proud of. That it was two parents.
They are very close. Yeah.
They talk about sex a lot.
Relationship grounds. Yeah.
Grounds them together.
I just had some memories.
I just had memories when I was,
we were doing a scene in the diner and
how the family after this big incident,
the families just hose the
hands together and they pray.
So to me that was a throwback to soulful
around the dinner table and the food.
And every,
and I even tell the actors to do it.
Everybody's just started overlapping,
talking dialogue, talking about food,
eat that hot sauce.
Don't put the hot sauce in there.
You better get to those
festivals for all that was just,
we're a family at the time.
Yeah. Yeah. And that's what makes for a
really authentic storytelling too. Um,
and you,
you mentioned the fun and the joy and the
humor and a lot of the things you were
shooting. How did you guys
maintain a sense of joy? You know,
I feel like black joy
and black excellence,
black happiness is so important
in terms of self care.
So like even when you're shooting
a scene that is so heavy,
that's emotionally charged,
how do you guys kind of come back and
find the joy in what you're doing? Well,
we have Regina Hall on sets,
right?
She has a jazz man. She's hilarious.
She always brought the joy,
all is brought the humor.
Um,
I think it's just kind of our natural
inclination to work through trauma that
way it's rely upon our humor and our joy.
And even though this experience was
so intense and traumatic at times,
yeah, there was always a sense of levity
and like all is a sense of community and
family.
Um,
and a feeling that if you really were
coming up against a wall emotionally and,
and you were tired and you know these
events and portraying them feel so heavy,
there's all this someone you could turn
to who would have your back. That's,
I think so
community and it's very finest.
Kind of having a nice family to shoot
with really helps with that kind of thing.
Yeah. Um, talking a little
bit more about, you know,
having that community and
that family all RMU onset, um,
in the movie,
I guess stars trying to figure out who
her community is even outside of her home.
So in her school I Williamson
Chris is a great character.
He's really interesting because he's
navigating allyship and trying to figure
out what that means for him,
how he fits into the scene,
how he fits into star's life.
Um,
if you guys had to I guess,
determine something that's important for
someone who is trying to become an ally
or trying to figure out how they can get
involved in movements and civil rights
and racial equality, what's
the first step? You know,
it, it can feel heavy right,
to, to step into a world you're not
used to and be like, you know what?
I'm with them.
How do you do that?
Um, one of my favorite lines when I,
when I read it in the script, it gave,
if I had this feeling of like a
retribution of like, oh my God,
I wish I'd had this in high school,
would have saved me so much
like internal strife. Um,
but there's this scene
where Chris says to star,
I don't see color.
I just see a person for who they are,
or like guys and star says,
if you don't see my blackness,
you don't see me. Amen. Uh,
and that was so validating to read on the
page because I think there's this idea
that owner,
to be an ally,
you have to look at the
other person as your equal.
But almost as if in the process of
doing that, in order to do that,
you have to discredit the aspects of
them that are different or that make them
more marginalized than you.
Um,
when really it should be the opposite.
When you look at someone
wants to be an ally to them,
it's so important that you are inclusive
of all the aspects of their identity
that make them them and see them.
And the way in which, you know,
those aspects of self, uh, dictate or,
or influenced their experience cause the
idea of, you know, oh, I don't see color.
It's like, really that's a great, great
intention of course. For sure. Yeah.
But it also rests upon the assumption
that we live in a post racial post
identity is society. And we all know
that that's the case. I would love,
we would love that, but that's
not where we're at. So the king,
and I don't even know if it's possible
for be in a place that, you know,
it doesn't,
it doesn't use identity or as,
as a lens through which we
primarily look at each other.
So I think being an ally is
about looking at someone and,
and not being afraid of this comfort of,
oh,
this person is different than me. They're
experience is different than me. Uh,
it's not about trying to,
um,
postulate their experience
as equal to yours,
but rather like respecting it and all of
its differences. Testing, learning. Yeah.
Learning about it. And I really think
sometimes it's just about shutting up,
sending down, shutting up and
listening, open those ears. Uh, yeah.
Cause I think that's was
really, um, you know,
when there's a group of people who have
historically taken up the space and been
very comfortable in that,
it is very uncomfortable to no longer
take up that space or, or you know,
control it or kind of demand
that you take up most of it.
And so it's different what it
looks like, discomfort, um, to,
you know,
people who have historically had
privilege is often just equity.
Um,
and that's what's really essential for
Chris to understand is he needs to take
step back and not take up as much
space even in their conversations.
Right.
Um,
stars really assertive in and making sure
that he's listening to her and saying,
you know, actually this is my time to
talk and listen to me raise my story,
here's my story.
And so I think that's a huge part of
it is stepping back and being like, oh,
I'm so used to taking up
all this space right here,
but actually let me step back.
I mean draw it back in and allow
this other person that the time,
um, and the space, he's in the word space
a lot in the time and the space, um,
to express themselves and express their,
their perspective.
Yeah. They're just like
two people. I'll be,
there's two lines in a movie to define
that. How an ally can work, you know,
um, Sabrina Carpenter
plays Hayley, right? Eh,
she says who else is going to
speak up for our people? Girl is,
she's a white individual saying that.
And then you got shook my car. Yeah.
You got Kj. APPA who plays Chris
in his line is being an ally.
What do you want me to do? Where do
you want me to? What? How can I help?
Absolutely.
So that shows the difference between the
two that we show two different sides.
One is about listening instead
of trying to follow somebody.
So being a part of it.
Yeah.
So, uh, one thing that's really
interesting is, you know,
as star is trying to figure out whether
or not she's going to use her voice and
speak up,
I mean we see that happening in
different ways in the world now with like
Hashtag activism, right?
So it's incredible that
we're using social media to,
to say their names and to learn more
about the stories that aren't really being
told without it.
Um,
but then bringing that into the real
world and taking another step is very
different.
So what advice do you have for
people who are learning to speak out,
who want to speak out,
who want to try and do something new,
but are kind of feeling that that little
bit of them that's holding them back.
What's the first step to,
to kind of opening yourself up
to trying something like that?
Hmm. Um, I really,
because I really love approaching activism
from a place of like art history and
humanity. And like when
Angie Thomas wrote this book,
she was still in college,
she was writing it on her lunch break,
lunch break.
That story too. There was a short, so
it's, sorry. Yeah. You know, she was
someone who is active socially active
on the Internet but wanted to find a
conduit through which she could express
it further or take the next step.
And for her that ended up writing a novel.
Okay.
I know they run it up and that that
has now been New York Times number one
bestseller for 83 weeks.
You know lievable I'm not saying
that's going to happen to it,
but I'll name find your own lane.
But I feel like I'm,
I dunno,
I really believe in the power of,
of expressing your activism
through your artistry.
And this was such a beautiful opportunity
cause it was this like synchronistic
like beautiful thing where everything
came together and we able to marry all of
the things that we cared
about. Um, and I feel like, um,
yeah, it's about expressing yourself
and whatever conduit that may be,
you know? Right. And so we,
I think we have some audience
questions coming up for you guys.
Two quick questions
before we have to that.
And you guys can kind of start lining
up at the mic if you have any questions
you want.
Okay.
Ask. Um, on a lighter
note for both of you guys,
you being a Chicago guy,
having lived here for so many years,
what's one of your favorite
places to eat in the city?
You know what, they got one and they
have one in Atlanta, but it's this, yeah,
this is not the same, but
right down on Wabash, you know,
right in front of Columbia college
was Harold's chicken. Okay.
Always still stop by when you buy.
Could we,
yeah, my wife. Can we stop by?
It's a classic. Okay.
And then for you, um,
I heard that your Harry
Potter fandom is real. Yes.
My heart is just skipping a beat as one.
So I want to know nothing to do with
the movie. Just my own curiosity.
If you had a patronus, what would it be?
Oh my God, that's so challenging. Um,
take a second. I'll start with
mine. It'd be a dolphin fan.
That's accurate, right?
That's good. Right?
I would like to think that moms
would be like a deer or something,
but I feel like it would
probably be like a mouse. Hey,
they're cute though.
And real fast.
Just never know anybody with questions.
Anyone who wants to ask anything.
If not, I will keep on going.
Don't tell me what the good time.
Do you want step up to the mic over here?
Okay.
So my question is, you talked about
really living this dichotomy, life,
uh,
grown up from where you are and then
having to really change that persona when
you go to school.
And I think about like Keith Stanfield
and sorry to bother you in the movie.
Now he switched to his white voice,
right?
Because he had to work and yet to
pretty much change the environment.
So I'm curious to know,
how have you been able to navigate your
life in your professional career where
you might have to change a mannerism a
little bit and kind of juxtaposing that
with your actual environment
from where you are back home.
How are you able to navigate through the
waters and kind of live two different
personalities?
Um,
and you know,
I mean I started going to that
school and I was 10 years old. Um,
so for me for a long time I had this
idea that there was something wrong with
code switching and that,
that there was something wrong with me
for having kind of this multi faceted
personality that shifted
depending on who I was around. Um,
and it kind of took me until I was a
bit older to understand that there's
nothing wrong with that and that
that's pretty natural considering the
circumstances. Uh, I used
to hate that, that, that,
that I had to make myself smaller, um, or,
or change who I was in order to feel
more accepted into that environment.
But learning that language of whiteness
and privilege has actually been really
invaluable to me when it comes
to navigating Hollywood, uh,
who would have thunk
it? So, so it's a tool.
It's a tool at the end of the day,
I don't necessarily look at it any
more as having to compromise myself.
I also have kind of witnessed the shift
happening where we are living in a
culture that is so transparently driven
by black culture and by blackness that
I'm starting to notice that even in
my spaces of work within my industry,
if I show up to that space
authentically as myself,
I seem to be more accepted than
I ever happened in the past.
And there seems to be this kind
of push for in inclusivity. Um,
that is new.
Um,
and I'm so I feel like I have to
compromise myself less and less. Um,
but I'm just more accepting of all the
different parts of me and the way that
they manifest in my mannerisms or
the way I talk all wrapped up nicely.
Okay.
Oh,
thank you guys so much for being here.
We are just honored to be able
to talk to you about this movie.
It really is such a movement right
now and we hope that it's going to be
received so well by so many people and
seeing all across the world and I really
think it's going to start a lot of great
conversations. I was telling you before,
my husband and I saw it last night,
we talked about it for
like an hour and a half,
just chatting and chatting and chatting.
And I think that's one of the really,
really special things about this movie
is that it allows for that conversation
in such a safe and open space, mixed
with humor, mixed with emotion,
mixed with, you know, your classic family.
And I think that's what's
really beautiful about it.
So congratulations to you guys
as a movie is out everywhere,
October 19th to make sure you go out and
see it. Also pick up Angie Thomas' book,
which is based off of,
it's also a brilliant read,
nice and easy all the way through
and just in a really robust story.
And it's kind of what inspired
you guys to be here this weekend.
Amen.
So you can see it tonight in Chicago,
right down the street, right? All
of you just got plans right tonight.
Like now you're done.
So you don't have to think about anything.
So George Tillman junior and
Amandla Stenberg, everybody.